joe biden arrive en arabie saoudite le
chemin qu'il a emprunté pour se rendre
ici est un symbole fort il est devenu le
premier président américain à prendre un
vol direct de tel aviv à jeddah les
avions israéliens seront désormais admis
dans l'espace aérien saoudien un pas de
plus vers la normalisation des relations
entre les deux pays today's et
l'historique des c'est une journée
historique déclare le premier ministre
d'israël les américains aimeraient que
l'arabie saoudite comme d'autres pays
arabes l'ont fait ces dernières années
reconnaisse officiellement l'état hébreu
il aimerait surtout que les saoudiens
augmentent leur production de pétrole
pour faire diminuer les prix de
l'essence même si pour y arriver il faut
tendre la main au prince héritier
mohammed bin salman
un rapport du renseignement américain a
conclu qu'il a ordonné le meurtre du
journaliste saoudien jamal khashoggi jo
buydens il lui en avoir parlé il a
répondu qu'il n'était pas responsable
et le sort d'une autre journaliste le
tourmente cette fois dans les
territoires palestiniens qu'il a visité
plus tôt shirin abou ac les vedettes de
la chaîne al jazira aussi américaine de
surcroît a été tué en mai par un tir
israélien alors qu'elle couvrait une
opération militaire
sa mort dit il est une perte énorme pour
le peuple palestinien qui perd une voix
importante d'anciens collègues ont placé
son portrait sur une chaise bien en
évidence devant le président américain
qui promet de faire la lumière sur ce
qui lui est arrivé
il faut tenir ses assassins responsable
indique le président de l'autorité
palestinienne le contraire pourrait
mener l escalade et au désespoir il dit
néanmoins tendre la main à israël
les conditions pour relancer le
processus de paix ne sont pas réunies 3
joe biden mais il promet de ne pas
abandonner
des points noirs fils le président by
day ne l'a pas caché l'objectif de ce
voyage dès le départ était de renforcer
ses relations avec ses deux principaux
alliés au moyen orient il n'a jamais
voulu rompre d'ailleurs ses relations
avec l'arabie saoudite at il dit mais
plutôt les réorienter ici sébastien
desrosiers radio-canada washington